Tension of the brain, and it is the brain's main instrument for observing the outside world.
Received by the eyes is broken down for transmission along the optic nerves, then reassembled by the brain.
I'm a little sunbeam. Well, strictly speaking, I should say that I'm a photon.
In other words, I'm a luminous particle. The only scientists can understand me. I'm really so particular.
It takes an Einstein to fathom me, because light equals energy, you see.
Now, I want you to remember what I've just said. I think it'll come in handy in a few minutes.
Because, look, here's an electron.
Now, she's made of electricity instead of light.
Let me stir her up a little.
The lighted electron is full of energy.
It's fun, isn't it?
One reflection.
Now, there must be a better way of putting it.
I mean, when I touch something, I reflect off it.
Watch.
Too good, but that's the general idea.
When you see an object, I bounce off it and into your eye.
And what's very important, I do this at the most incredible speed.
Oh, wrong way.
Back again.
You must admit that wasn't bad.
I've just been around the world seven times at the speed of 300,000 kilometres per second.
That's a little Sunbeam's cruising speed.
Who else could do that?
Only another little photon, like me.
You can applaud now.
Caught you there, didn't I?
But you won't get rid of me before I've introduced all the other photons.
There are far too many of us to count.
Provide warmth and light that make life on Earth possible.
Without us, this planet would be barren, cold and dark, like so many others.
Without us, everything would be grey.
because we create color quickly and look at this butterfly it's so beautiful does it have such
beautiful colors on its wings mom to believe i know but we're invisible to them is that a fact
just watch this see nothing absolutely nothing look why now what do you think of that my friend
i really thought you were joking at first you know we're invisible yet we make things visible
for them picture the eye is not focused sharply on the subject tell the ciliary muscles they must
tighten up and refocus the lens.
And you better relay my instructions to the oculomotor muscles.
I want the eyes turned half a degree to the right.
But a preciferous roadhog ought to be arrested and put away for life.
Speedy by nature ought to be arrested and put away for life.
Puffing and panting doesn't impress me, young fellow.
I know what a day's work is, and believe me, I do it.
It's not exactly a picnic, this job, and we don't get much credit or cooperation.
Can I...
Well, if you want to, cheeky young devil.
Chief, my job is no bed of roses either.
Tell you we're short-staffed and I do a lot of overtime and while we're wasting time and breath, they've got a fuzzy picture upstairs.
Let's see. Adjustment of focus.
Tension of ciliary muscles to force five.
Okay?
Okay.
He's on working hard.
A swarm of little neurotransmitters is on its way to deliver the message to the fibers of the ciliary muscles.
To remain your most obedient servant.
Okay, guys. Force five contraction.
Suppose they're up to the blithering idiots.
Just half a degree to the right. That was all that I wanted.
And that was precisely the message I sent.
Someone's entitled to make a tiny mistake every now and then.
Oh, I see. Correction. Adjustment to the field of vision.
One-tenth of a degree to the left.
The left, you'd think they'd know what they wanted the first time.
Very well, then.
Left it is. One-tenth of a degree, no more, no less.
Here, give this correction top priority, please.
One-tenth of a degree to the left, if you please.
Listen here, you. I've got enough on my place already.
Don't bother me.
The boss is watching us.
And a very good day to you, Professor Globus.
It's an absolutely beautiful day, isn't it?
That's right, it's so fine, we could do with some carotene units in this set.
There they are.
Right on time, too.
Forget it.
Done it again!
Oh, come!
What?
They lack in experience, they make up in enthusiasm.
How true.
Never heard of vitamins.
Vitamins are physical fitness and health itself.
With albino fun in life whatsoever.
Light goes through us, but we don't feel a thing.
Light doing.
Just passing through is a reflection of the outside world with its shapes and colors.
The shapes and colors end up, Professor.
Ah, well, after all these little sunbeams have traveled a great distance,
they end up in a marvelous place called the retina at the back of the eye.
That's where their signal is received and passed on.
The photons strike the retina, which is made up of densely packed cells which are sensitive to light.
From their shapes, these cells are called the rods and the cones.
Have you all got that?
Yes, Professor Clovis.
Good. Shall I continue?
Please.
Now here's what happens when a ray of light strikes the retina.
The information is reflected, then transmitted.
Neurotransmitters make the connection.
Then the information is passed from cell to cell along the optic nerve.
The information reaches the brain.
The left brain deals with the signals from the right eye and vice versa.
It's curious, isn't it?
Eyes work to let me see in color, do you know?
Your eyes don't really do the seeing, Peter. It's your brain.
Does the brain have eyes, then?
Yes, in a way.
I thought, the brain is what we use for thinking, isn't it?
How can the brain see? I don't understand it.
I wish someone would explain the whole thing to me.
I wish somebody would explain the whole thing to me.
What a question to ask.
Well, we'd better not disturb Maestro, you know.
No, he's far too busy for that, isn't he?
Too busy to explain anything.
What's the matter? What on earth do you want now?
I want to know how it is that I can see with my brain.
Oh, well, that's not such an easy question to answer, young man.
It's a miracle, you see, a wonderful process, and I'm not sure I understand it myself.
But I like a boy with a thirst for knowledge.
Climb in, and I'll try to explain.
Come this way, Sonny.
The place to understand and to see is to know.
Here, take a seat.
Thank you, sir.
Look at the screen and tell me what you see.
Well, what is it?
It's an arrow, I think.
It's an arrow that gets along going shorter.
Well, do you think you've seen it before?
No, I haven't, sir.
Oh, it's turning. It's a weather vane.
Well done. Now, my boy, which part of you saw the weather vane?
Your brain or your eyes? It was your brain, wasn't it?
Now, watch this. I'll give you a clue.
It's the sun, of course, isn't it?
No, it's not the sun. I'm wrong. It's an orange.
Red disc hasn't changed at all. Watch.
It's trickery. Now it's a flower.
And now what is it? You see, it all depends, doesn't it?
Ha-ha! It all depends on what your brain remembers.
The decision was made up here, that you were looking at an orange.
Take it, you've earned a prize.
I'll have one of those.
Me too. I'm due for a treat.
You see how important interpretation is?
Is this a vase or two faces?
Eyes receive the signals, but the brain has to decide how to decode them.
And besides, both eyes don't always see the same picture.
Hold your thumb right out in front of you and then shut one of your eyes.
now open it and close the other and just keep on doing it. It looks as if it's moving. That's right,
it is moving from side to side. Take on the left. I have to go now. Breakfast is ready and mum will
be looking for me. You showed me such interesting things. Thanks a lot. So here you are. I've been
looking everywhere. I was here all the time, mum. I ate an orange. An orange? Mm-hmm. I got it from
an old man that lives in my brain. Got a surprise for you. A surprise, mum? What is it? Yes. A
Ball, or maybe marbles, or a penknife?
Not at all. You haven't guessed it yet.
You'll have to try a lot harder than that.
Now shut your eyes. Don't peep.
All right, then. Now you can look.
I'm a puppy. Can't believe it. Is he really mine?
Mm-hmm.
Gee, thanks, Mum. Thanks.
Listen, Peter, dear, a puppy is not a toy.
He's your responsibility.
You'll have to house-train him and teach him obedience.
You can play with him when you come home from school,
and in the meantime, make sure he can't run away.
Right you are, Mum. I think I'm going to call him Roly-Poly.
You be a good dog while I'm at school. We'll play when I come home.
Roly-Poly, be a good boy now. Sit. Stay.
Poor little thing. I just know he's been run over by a bus and I'll never see him again.
Don't upset yourself, Peter. He can't have wandered very far away.
Here, paused by sadness.
Roly-Poly's come.
You see, Peter, you were wrong to let yourself get into such a state.
I just knew that he had to be somewhere close by.
We weep when we're sad and also when we're joyful.
Stay outside now. I think we better go in, roly-poly, my friend.
From expressing emotion, tears are necessary to keep our eyes healthy.
Where did tears come from? Let's find out.
Excellent, excellent. But there's still a certain je ne sais quoi that's missing.
I think throw in some salt.
Yes, I'll...
Hang on a minute there, chaps. I'd like six units of your salt, if you don't mind.
Now there's some dust in the air. Pour a few tears immediately to wash it away.
Becoming irritated. Increase production of tears immediately.
And don't forget to use germ-killing additives in the mixture.
I've been running around like a mad thing all day.
Listen, you. Those tears are 100% pure.
I'm warning you, get out now before you pollute them any further.
I'm prepared to give you one last chance.
But if you won't do as I say, I will take your name.
Oh, what a blithering idiot you are. Serves you right.
Now, catch hold of the life belt.
Let that be a lesson to you.
This is not a public swimming bath.
These tears must be kept free of impurities.
Now, get on with your work.
Those are the only tears I'll shed over him.
I've just learned that the eye is irritated.
Increase production immediately and let our specialist cleaning enzymes know they'll be needed.
Well done, little scrubbers!
If you don't know isosomes, a highly trained squad of specialist technicians who clean the surface of the eye.
I know, I know, I was only teasing. Now off to work with you.
Then get this eye thoroughly clean. We'll have no viral conjunctivitis while I'm in charge of the squad.
Musty things. Something rather suspicious up there under the eyelid.
I've been spotted, guys. Those enzymes are dangerous. We'll have to split up and make a run for it.
You make a dash first while we cover your rear.
Come on, lads, we'll give these filthy viruses no quarter.
Let's make ourselves scarce.
Go away from me!
Eyes are red.
What happens if I told you not to rub your eyes with dirty hands?
If you do that, my boy, you'll get conjunctivitis.